[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here you know tech
companies straight up lie to us
sometimes right like there's now there's
different types of lies and there's
definitely different levels to this
honestly most of it is harmless
but it is fascinating and i think you
might be surprised by how much stuff we
might take for granted that's not
actually real so i and many other very
optimistic people have been waiting for
the new tesla roadster to be the first
reasonable two-door electric sports car
ever since it was unveiled five years
ago in 2017 can you believe it's been
five years they originally said it would
come out in 2020
and then 2020 came and went and it was a
bit of a weird year so then 2021
happened
still nothing now it's 20 22. this car
is probably not coming out until 2024 at
least but you know maybe that's not a
lie you know that's something they were
actually trying and hoping to achieve
and then it got delayed a while fine
but there were a lot of other little
things elon said on stage that night
that were
let's just say
clever ways of framing certain
information the new tesla roadster
will be the fastest
car
production part ever made period 0 to 60
in 1.9 seconds this would be the first
time that any car has broken two seconds
at zero to 60. so that
actually turned out to be untrue because
plaid model s came out last year and it
also has a sub two seconds zero to sixty
but these zero to sixties should have a
little uh asterisk up in the corner next
to it because they are with something
called roll out subtracted so tesla's
triple motor plaid model s is listed at
a 1.99 second 0-60 and at least that one
does have an asterisk on the site with
the asterisk meaning with rollout
subtracted so certain performance cars
list their 0 to 60 time with a one foot
of subtracted roll out which might sound
a little weird but this is a metric that
comes from the drag racing world
basically when a car lines up to do the
0-60 test or a drag test it's measuring
whether or not you've started by whether
or not your tire has broken the light
beams across the starting line so
there's one pre-staging light and one
staging light seven inches later the
clock starts when the tires are no
longer breaking that plane but there is
a small bit of speed gathered as the car
launches before it stops blocking that
first light
and then the second light
that is the one foot roll out a fast car
can reach five to six miles an hour in
that one foot roll out which cuts the
reported 0 to 60 time anywhere from 0.2
to 0.3 seconds that's actually a a
bigger gap the harder the car launches
so every real world test of the model s
of people on the street going from 0 to
60 or even on drag strip 0 to 60 it's
always been measured at like 2.15
to 2.25 seconds which is still
absolutely ridiculous but by measuring
with one foot rollout tesla was able to
achieve 1.99 seconds i assume they
achieved it at least one time in order
for them to put it on their website
because that's a way cooler headline and
a way more impressive stat
but that should have that asterisk next
to it and i assume the tesla roadster's
time was also measured with one foot
roll out but it doesn't have the
asterisk so is that a lie
well no
but that number can be a little
deceiving without the extra context i
said turn killing our code our battery
pack 10 000 newton meters of torque if
you know what that means it's just
stupid
so that 10 000 newton meters of torque
is another one that's a pretty absurd
number not that people are buying sports
cars just for the torque number but that
translates to about 7
400 pound feet of torque which is just
ridiculous for context here's how that
would line up with some cars you may
recognize some of the most famous
fastest cars ever made seems a little
hard to believe they're this far out in
front right but torque is one of those
numbers and metrics that's been around
for a long time and it's a little bit
different in gas cars versus electric
cars so as explained so eloquently by
donut media i'm going to link their
video about that below the like button
torque is a measurement of turning force
and in this case the force being applied
by the engine is turning the wheels so
when manufacturers list the horsepower
and the torque of a car they typically
list the torque right at the engine
crankshaft but by the time it gets to
the wheels with parasitic losses of the
drivetrain it's a lower number same
thing with torque which also gets
multiplied by the gear ratios in the
drivetrain but electric cars don't have
all those gears they have what's called
direct drive and so they make a lot of
torque through one large gear so after
multiplication the number is much more
impressive from the wheels than from the
crankshaft at the motors so they've
chosen to report wheel torque so the 10
000 newton meter number that elon said
for the roadster is likely
perfectly legit very real it's not a lie
it's just this new number is a little
deceiving without the context that it's
a different measurement of torque from
what we've gotten from every other gas
car for decades just a little extra word
there wheel torque makes a big
difference and this isn't just tesla by
the way this is the same thing happened
with the hummer ev which got announced
that it would have 11 500 pound-feet of
torque but as engineering explained also
pointed this out when you divide by the
gear ratios of each of the motors you
end up at about a thousand pound feet of
torque at the motors the way it's
normally reported but let's shift gears
a bit pun intended because you know at
least we're talking about real products
what teslas and hummers are gonna ship
they're eventually real and that's great
and on the other side of that spectrum
is vaporware so vaporware is defined as
a product that's been advertised but is
not yet available to buy either because
it's only a concept or because it's
still being written or designed or built
so is vaporware a lie
i mean there's there's lots of vaporware
everywhere i mean from sony's concept
car at ces that i'm telling you is never
going to ship as is
to uh bmw's color changing ix from ces
with the e-ink exterior it looks so sick
but i think we all know that's not going
to be a real car that we can buy but
then there are also some real products
that companies announce with the
intention of making them
and then
things go a little sideways like do you
remember samsung's bixby enabled speaker
called galaxy home that looked like a
barbecue grill that was announced in
2018
then a year went by nothing shipped in
2019 there are people that started
poking samsung and they had to come out
and confirm with a statement that it
wasn't canceled yet they're still
working on it but then in 2020 samsung
quietly removed all the coming soon
verbiage from their site and wouldn't
respond with any official statements
about it so they're probably hoping we
forgot about that one or how about air
power apple spent a few minutes on stage
raving about this new product a charging
mat that would charge your phone and
your watch and your airpods all at once
and it was to be the future of charging
this is not possible with current
standards but our team knows how to do
this yeah
they didn't they didn't probably the
biggest red flag was that at the actual
event they had a single non-working
dummy unit in the hands-on area and then
everybody left and went home
and air power just kind of quietly
disappeared nobody ever saw or heard
about airpower again eventually the
airpower project was officially
cancelled by apple i explained why that
disappeared with the video up here that
you can click or it's linked below if
you want to watch that but i think the
strangest tech company lies though
come from
industry standards or terms that are
just straight up
outdated because that's just the way
they are they're not even lying on
purpose
and most of these come from the photo
video industry and i don't just mean how
someone might say oh we're filming
something when really there's no film
anymore we're recording or if somebody
doesn't know
because they're too young that the save
button is based on a real physical
floppy drive it used to be an actual
thing you could carry it goes deeper
than that for example the one inch
sensor might have heard a lot about it
it's not one inch
it's not one inch vertically it's not
one inch horizontally it's not one inch
diagonally no part of a one inch sensor
is actually one inch now you might have
seen that point and shoots like sony's
rx100 famously use a one-inch sensor or
that there's even a couple new
smartphones popping up like the sharp
aquos or leica smartphone or the sony
xperia pro i that have huge one-inch
sensors but despite all the headlines
and all the articles and titles and
captions and tweets and anything else
you might read if you're thinking that a
one-inch sensor refers to a one-inch
measurement in any way then you'd be
wrong just like i was when i first found
this so it turns out a one-inch sensors
dimensions
are about 13.2 millimeters by 8.8
millimeters now if you're not already
annoyed by switching between imperial
and metric you've realized that that's
less than an inch in both directions but
what about the diagonal well with a
little pythagorean theorem that
calculates out to 15.9 millimeters
which is also not one inch so how did we
get here how is this a one inch sensor
well if you go back to the beginnings of
video recording these earliest cameras
were vacuum tube cameras so just like
old crt tvs use cathode ray tubes the
earliest tv cameras instead of a digital
sensor had physical tubes with a lens at
the front and electronics inside them to
capture photons to capture light so the
bigger the tube the more light it could
capture it would redirect all that light
to a sensitive piece inside the tube and
at the time people would refer to the
size of the tube by the diameter of the
tube so when we started using one inch
diameter tubes the sensitive piece
inside those had gotten to about 13 by 8
millimeters so fast forward 50 plus
years here we are today with these
amazing digital sensors and all this new
equipment but today still we refer to
the size of the sensor
not by the actual
measurement of the sensor
but by the measurement of the
hypothetical tube
diameter that would be needed
to fit the sensor of today's current
size
wow so today we have one inch sensors
they're called one inch sensors because
the diameter of the tube that would fit
a sensor that's .63 inches diagonally
would be a one-inch tube but it's a 0.63
inch sensor so that actually means all
of the other sensor measurements that
you have relative to one inch are also
relative to this hypothetical inch so
the half inch sensor isn't half an inch
it's half of the hypothetical one inch
sensor ah so is it a lie when these
companies say that their products their
cameras have a one inch sensor
yes and no i mean no if you know what
they're talking about even if it is a
lie though it is a pretty harmless slide
because a one-inch sensor is still a
pretty big sensor yeah but there are all
kinds of products that have come out
where the big selling feature is the
one-inch sensor like you might remember
the dji air 2s drone when it was
unveiled the spec sheet on hasselblad's
site and on dji site and all the
articles it all says one inch sensor
like that's a one inch sensor guys or
maybe take the insta 360 one r you can
pay extra money for a one inch addition
which is a 5k capable one inch sensor
one inch sensor
one inch sensor like every headline i
can remember seeing about the sony
xperia pro i this crazy new smartphone
mentioned the one-inch sensor and even
my video guilty talks about how they're
using a one-inch sensor which at no
point actually says the real dimensions
of the sensor now sony makes most of
these actual sensors we're talking about
and sony's own website for this phone
says it has a one-inch sensor but wait
there's a little asterisk and if you
scroll
all the way down
and read into what that actually stands
for it turns out it's a one inch
1.0 type sony image sensor
ah see it is a pretty big ask to ask the
entire photography industry to redefine
sensor sizes but that is probably how we
should be referring to these sensors as
1.0 type sensors because they're not
actually one inch sensors but you know
sony's own website uses both terms at
any given point interchangeably to refer
to the size of the sensor and i think if
you ask these companies they'd probably
like to have you believe that they're
one-inch diagonal sensors if they never
clarify then
maybe that's a lie by a mission
i don't know how do you feel about that
part of my job as a reviewer i think is
to sort through
all these statements from companies that
get made all the time and one figure out
how real they are
and then two if they're not real find
out how
harmless or harmful
is that lie because it's definitely a
spectrum i remember when there was this
huge uproar about transparent backed
phones where you could kind of see
through the back of the phone and some
of the components inside and it was this
really cool nerdy design but it turned
out this was just a sticker and the
components that you were looking at
weren't really the working parts of the
phone they led you to believe they were
so is that a lie
yeah totally but it did feel pretty
harmless like the whole point of having
the transparent back look is just to
look kind of cool and nerdy and it still
did accomplish that so i felt like that
wasn't something that was a huge deal
but on the other side of the spectrum
companies will actively try to trick you
and there is harmful versions of lies
there's stuff like
vaporware there's stuff like i don't
know huawei when they started lying
about photos to claim that they were
taken with their newest smartphone but
then they were caught multiple times
taking it with a dslr or a bigger camera
that is misleading that that is
potentially harmful to a customer that
thinks they're going to get one thing
but then doesn't
so i point that out
and hopefully we can all make more
informed decisions together that way and
everybody wins
thanks for watching catch you guys the
next one
peace
[Music]